hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
just checking in on you who what's going
on
how are you how's your life how's things
going for you
in your world i hope they're doing all
right i hope they're doing all right uh
[ __ ] my sports world is pretty good
i gotta tell you that you know we for
some reason just keep getting paired up
with um
you know the washington teams bro
uh celtics played the wizards and the
bruins are in a great series with uh the
capitals
a series that could go either way every
single game has gone into overtime
game one overtime tj
oh capitals go up one game to none
uh second game bruins win it in overtime
the great marchand put it away and then
last night riley scored for the bruins
everybody's jumping all over that goalie
or whatever it's like it was also double
overtime you know people get [ __ ]
tired you screw up things happen
but what's his face uh alex ovechkin
i thought he did a great thing there he
[ __ ] flipped out
started screaming and yelling that's
what you got to do
let people know this isn't a joke all
right trying to [ __ ] win some [ __ ]
here
i don't even know what happened somebody
said oh the goalie went around the wrong
side
which i don't understand what do you
mean he went around the wrong side as
long as he gets to the front side to try
to block it
i thought it was the defenseman's fault
that's not what other people's saying
other people say well he [ __ ] went
around the wrong side
he should have gone back to the same
saudi cape
the defenseman went a little wide it's
like
what are you talking about capitals alex
ovechkin has angry reaction
after loss uh to bruins
uh watch alex ovechkin's angry reaction
after bruins
in case you don't believe us alex
ovechin doesn't like losing
and he's especially doesn't like losing
on a preventable play
i mean could you just insert every
single [ __ ] nhl player there that may
explain why the washington capital star
was so incensed
oh jesus christ i'm not even gonna
[ __ ] read that
should i read it all right let's just
[ __ ] read well i can't read it
because every time i go to move it this
other stupid ad gets in the way how many
[ __ ] things can they have
clicked on this website
i'm trying to read the [ __ ] article
what is this a porn site um with 548
remaining in double overtime
of game three in the bruins 2021 stanley
clay
2021 stanley cup playoff first round
series versus the washington capitals
boston
winger craig smith capitalized oh that
was riley
on an apparent miscommunication between
the capitals goaltender
ilya samsonov and defenseman justin
schultz to score the game-winner
uh ovechkin uh who was on the bench at
the time of smith's goal
broke his stick in frustration the nbc
broadcast then caught the washington
capital
yelling in the direction of one or
multiple of his teammates as they skated
off the ice
he's just holding them accountable it's
unclear who the subject of ovechkin's
ire but his anger is understandable
you know who he's yelling at um
boston also dominated the overtime
period 3017 edge that's what i think
right there
i thought like we just took it to them
and they um both overtimes i just didn't
think they had the jump
in their in their their their legs there
they just looked like
we were dominating them after we
dominated in the first overtime i
thought that washington was going to
come out like you know
was probably going to get the better of
us in the second one i just kind of felt
like we were going to lose
last night and they still came out flat
and uh
i think that that has more to do with it
than that one last play
so i'm looking for my prediction is
the capitals come out on fire the next
game and they tie it up 2-2
um that seems to be what usually ends up
happening is that [ __ ] toilet still
running this goddamn [ __ ]
little rubber flangers jesus christ
unbelievable you know why can't they
just [ __ ] make it out of something
that just
lasts one of the worst things that
corporations were ever allowed to do
is is just make [ __ ] disposable
i i think in the future like
we'll finally actually have to recycle
rather than just having recyclable
recycled bins you know put it in
recycling
and we'll throw it all in the same dump
because i think that that's what they're
doing
um for the most part but i'm hoping this
younger generation
can somehow write all the wrongs of
everything that all the generations
before have done this is just it's
[ __ ]
ridiculous in this this constant
having to replace [ __ ] that if they just
made it right
you're done you know they got to bring
back repairmen
for tvs and they got to stop making [ __ ]
disposable
every five [ __ ] seconds there's some
new update that updates that [ __ ]
fills up your thing and then you can't
use it
ah jesus anyway and then the celtics
played the uh
we played the washington wizards um
it was a great game during the first
half pulled away in the [ __ ] third
quarter
in the fourth quarter uh jason tatum and
uh
walker had big games i was really
excited to see walker [ __ ] step
up and have a big game in a game that
[ __ ] counted i hope he keeps doing
that
because now we have um
[Music]
the brooklyn nets in the first round
which is uh
you know the brooklyn nets are basically
everything that's been wrong with the
nba
that started with the kobe shack phil
jackson pylon [ __ ] lakers
and uh it's sort of a joke of a [ __ ]
leak
when it comes to that [ __ ] um
as far as i'm concerned as a sports fan
where it's like i watch it for
competition i don't just watch it to see
[ __ ]
10 of the best guys all pile on two
[ __ ] teams
um and then walk around afterwards and
be like how many more do we need to win
and then we're as good as jordan
that's [ __ ] stupid and my boston
celtics were guilty of it in 2008 we
went out and we bought a [ __ ]
championship i hate that [ __ ]
championship
it's stupid the whole thing was [ __ ]
stupid we went from last place to first
place because we took out a [ __ ]
wallet
um pylon pylon 409
um so i'll sort of be watching that just
because um
i like this celtics team because it's
essentially uh
for the most part draft picks uh walker
was a free agent
um we've kind of kept the same group of
people but like that whole [ __ ] thing
of just like hey let's all get on a
yacht
and just sit around just decide let's
which where do you guys want to go
well if i went here would you guys come
here with me i don't want to play you
it'd be too hard everybody just play
with each other
boom little kids don't even do that
outdoor recess um
so anyway you know i i keep getting all
of these [ __ ] you know i've been
getting
i don't even know why i'm gonna [ __ ]
bring this up but like people are going
like hey you know talk about palestine
and israel it's like i don't even know
where our [ __ ] vice president is
um i can't tell you this what i do find
this what i do find
fascinating is uh
just like in sports where people pick
the story up from
so this guy writes column from call
pressure from american
left for first of all i love that it's
politicized
american left for israel cease fire will
only
strengthen iran um
i just love how people seem like they
always like whatever side they're
arguing
with for they act like history began and
right here
and right here
so really i mean it's just a really
complex
thing this person is like if hamas
listed as a terrorist organization by
the united states
state department launched thousands of
rockets the u.s what would you have the
american president do
fire back you'd say of course it's like
well yeah if that's where you started
no one ever goes why is there that group
what are they upset with
and then once you get to that then you'd
have to go to jewish people well why the
[ __ ] did we go to israel
why do we go there because of this [ __ ]
where did that [ __ ] happen because of
this [ __ ] and everybody like starts the
[ __ ] argument
like and history begins now it begins
now or whatever
um [ __ ] horrible situation
especially because i've been over there
briefly
you just see just a bunch of beautiful
people over there it's just really a
[ __ ] uh
you know it's just a [ __ ] terrible
goddamn thing over there's always the
oppressor
and then the oppressed and then
everybody
you know depending on what side you are
of the [ __ ] it's like these cop
[ __ ] shows that i'm watching these
cop movies that i'm watching where the
white cop goes in
you know to uh you know
clean up the non-white neighborhood
because he's sick of what's happening to
his city
and he goes into those neighborhoods and
they just pick up the story there it's
like
why is that neighborhood like that what
happened to the
nobody chooses to live like that
but that's not how it's presented it's
just presented yeah these people there
they're animals they're prone to
violence
oh [ __ ] thing is silly it's not silly
it's sad
um which is something i'm trying to uh
i'm trying to avoid being for the rest
of my [ __ ] life and right as i was
turning the corner
you know with my whole [ __ ] therapy
and i thought i'd i
had found the [ __ ] basement
you know i literally walked around for
two weeks and all my anger had gone and
then i
some other [ __ ] uncovered and then it
just goes it came
right the [ __ ] back
last night and now today i feel better
though i'm like all right i'm gonna
[ __ ]
now i have to go through this [ __ ] i
gotta [ __ ] deconstruct this [ __ ] to
figure why this now
you know i got my own [ __ ] uh good
guy bad guy [ __ ] [ __ ] going on in
my [ __ ] head
um fortunately i'm sober while i'm doing
it sober
um and i'm trying not to give into this
whole [ __ ] idea that suddenly if you
take like hallucinogens
it heals your brain i'm like yeah all
right that seems a little
simple this is one thing here is like
a neuroscientist describes her dmt
trip so
i haven't watched it yet
um let me just look for the comments
here to see what they say
i just have to feel that there's always
a price to pay for everything right
there's never just like
you know it's like having a flat stomach
the price you pay
is you have to eat healthy food
[Laughter]
and i know healthy food is [ __ ] good
for you and everything like that but
it's not the most exciting [ __ ]
on the planet sitting down as i always
call them eating a
sad salad um
is not the uh i don't know
it's not the [ __ ] most exciting thing
and then sitting down and eating what i
ate last night
where i kind of um have decided that
like i was just gonna go for the whole
oreo family
you know i know what the regular ones
taste like and then they had double
stuff and last night you know but with
double stuff i still felt myself
taking off the one cookie and then
sticking it to the other one
so then they had mega stuff and i
finally i had some of those last night
and uh those things are just wrong on
all level
and i i've reached the end
i've reached the end um
it's funny i look up dmt and so much of
it is joe rogan
uh joe roga dmt joe rogan
and so and so compare dmt experiences
russell brand wants to know about dmt on
joe rogan
i mean is that where i go
um
that's hilarious and for some reason
says jerry seinfeld on reunions and why
he hates
newman somehow that's in there with dmt
joe rogan dan aykroyd talk about dmt
what the [ __ ]
there's another one dmt i gotta watch
some of these things
i gotta see what the deal is i don't
know that shit's scary as hell to me i
think i'd rather just try to go the
old-fashioned way
you know i kind of look at it like it's
like my shoulders i could have just gone
in and got an operation
or some [ __ ] instead i've spent four
years starting
and failing trying to [ __ ] rehab
these things with bands
oh god um anyway
yeah i have nothing to talk about except
sadness
of figuring out who the [ __ ] i am which
i don't want to talk about because i
don't want you
to [ __ ] bum you guys out so let's
[ __ ] talk about last night
last night i did um
i did a couple of shows i did some
stand-up and i was having um
just had a [ __ ] great time
great time doing that i was really
worried because i was going through all
this [ __ ] that when i went on stage
i was gonna bring it up there and i
still felt
light and i still didn't feel like i was
being
uh you know i wasn't being mean
i was saying [ __ ] up [ __ ] but there
was a lightness to it
um i don't know
i just want to get back on the road so i
can keep running from my past
that's what i want to do i don't want to
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] anymore
um yeah
jesus christ anyway
let's just go to the [ __ ] headline
shall we people i'll just gonna i'm just
gonna riff on headlines
i don't know what else to tell you other
than i'm i am i'm watching that dirty
the dirty hairy [ __ ] and i mean i am
obsessed with the ford custom 500
four-door i'd never heard of that car i
was always into
the galaxies and then there was the fair
lines and all of that
and a lot of those exist but i'll tell
you this trying to find a 1968 ford
custom 500
four-door there's pictures of them but
trying to find one like you know most of
those cars you just look it up and
there's a bunch of people selling them
or whatever
there's just not a lot um there's not a
lot out there
um i can tell you that what else do we
got here right
israel palestine a little [ __ ] sad
[ __ ] there
headlines top stories um
air strike turns gaza's schools into
shelters officials fear
covet 19 may turn them into super
spreader centers yeah but they have the
[ __ ] why don't you just
why don't you just give everybody the
[ __ ] vaccine
i don't understand how we have a cure
and you know why don't we send some
stuff over there
right and does that mean that in
palestine there's going to be the same
thing going on
and if so why don't you bring them up uh
michael cohen
trump will flip on family and criminal
investigation
wait a second wait a minute i didn't
know there was a criminal investigation
on trump
oh jesus christ this [ __ ] guy the
trump organization is headquartered
in trump's new york's trump tower
um i love that it's written in gold it's
gold and black
you know it's really new money but he
grew up rich it's [ __ ] weird
all right new york attorney general
leticia james or latia is investigating
former president donald trump's business
the trump organization in a criminal
capacity
what you really should say is they're
trying to make something stick on this
guy so he won't run for president again
uh her office says ratcheting up
scrutiny of trump's real estate
transactions and other dealings
uh the state attorney general is forcing
this is hilarious because why wasn't
this done before he became president
they don't want him back they're going
to try to bury this guy i'm not saying
it's right or wrong
i'm not saying this guy's a good guy i'm
definitely not saying that but like
i'm just acting like they're not just
doing the job here there's a reason
they're doing this
the state attorney general is joining
forces with manhattan manhattan district
attorney
cyrus vance jr who has been conducting a
separate criminal inquiry into trump's
business practices and possible
insurance or financial fraud
as well as alleged hush money payments
to two women
who said they had affairs with trump
before he became president
wait a second you can get arrested for
that trump's business practices and
possible insurance for that yeah or
financial fraud
as well as alleged hush money payments
to women isn't hutch money payments to
two women isn't that just some uh
scuttlebutt those other things you can
go to jail for right
uh trump has in the past refused to
cooperate with investigations calling
them
instances of political persecution
earlier this year the u.s supreme court
cleared the way for vance to subpoena
tax
trump's tax returns and other financial
documents here's a brief recap
of where things currently stand
prosecutors team up
the nuke oh my god johnny
he better get he better reboot that
[ __ ] tv show so you can keep the
[ __ ] wolves at bay
[Laughter]
oh god such horseshit you know what's
funny is if he [ __ ] did what the
people who were prosecuting him wanting
to do
they'd never look at his goddamn tax
returns there's so many [ __ ] people
in this country that
are so filthy rich and don't even pay
taxes
don't even [ __ ] pay taxes and you
know what you know what they're learning
all they have to do is grease the
politicians
and greece the judges just don't run
for president and win and piss off half
the country because then they're going
to come and get you
then they grab their guns and come and
get you who is that biggie
um your boston red sox are 26 and 18
26 and 18 have a game one game lead
and the al east atleast is tight tight
race
game up on the rays game and a half up
on the blue jays and the yankees
and they uh they got eight games on the
[ __ ]
orioles who just absolutely suck
um no not too bad 17 and 25.
you got a 40 chance they're gonna win
right is that what it is um
white sox are crushing it so let's see
the twin stake oh that's
the tigers stink the royal stake
so far marin is stink
the angels stink the rangers i was all
excited that we
we we were gonna sweep the [ __ ]
angels till we gave up that bomb in the
[ __ ] ninth inning
he gave up that [ __ ] bomb in the
[ __ ] ninth inning i [ __ ] up my car
yesterday
i don't think i've ever had a car
accident in my life
just the [ __ ] that i'm going through i
was sitting there thinking about it and
i went around the corner and i just
[ __ ] sideswiped
a parked car it was this truck that had
this big ass
bumper [ __ ] crease
both doors on the other side it's just
like
jesus [ __ ] christ what is the purpose
of figuring out who you are
if you're gonna [ __ ] up your car um
i don't know oh jesus christ of course
there's no [ __ ] advertising this week
there's no goddamn advertising i wonder
why that is
what did i what did i do now who the
[ __ ] did i who the [ __ ]
did i annoy um
all right people you know what i think
i'm gonna have to wrap this thing up
early because i have too much [ __ ]
i got too many demons floating around my
[ __ ] head and i'm not gonna burden
you guys with it
um la restaurant attack investigated as
anti-semitic hate crime i thought it
said asthmatic
like jesus christ the food was so bad
somebody had a goddamn asthma attack
ellie you know i walked out of this show
last night and there was one star wars
fan standing there
and it's so [ __ ] up he's like hey bill
it's like ah jesus christ right because
i was i'm going through all of this [ __ ]
and i angrily signed in like five of
these [ __ ] things
now i feel like a douche for doing it
but there's just something about that
[ __ ] gig where i walk out and i don't
have the choice
i have to go buy him and i have to sign
that takes me back
to when i was a kid and it was all that
sit down
shut the [ __ ] up and eat it like you
don't have a choice the 70s and 80s it
takes me back to that so i feel like a
[ __ ]
i got to stop do i got to get myself in
the right mindset for when i walk up
that's part of the gig you're a
privileged guy but the
but you know you're not allowed to
[ __ ] be going through some [ __ ] right
um all right let's look this up
l.a restaurant attack is being
investigated now jesus christ
now there's an ad here as an
anti-semitic hate crime
tech at west side sushi restaurant
investigated as possible anti-semitic
hate crime now wait a minute i thought
sushi was japanese cuisine did they
convert
an attack on diners outside of a sushi
restaurant by people
shouting slogans against israel is being
invented now how the [ __ ]
d are you in america outside of a
[ __ ] is this in america you're
outside
a sushi restaurant
and you can figure out that somebody
walking out is jewish
it was a violent brawl outside of well
this is just terrible
the attack came can't those can't people
just [ __ ] go in and eat
sushi that has a little bit of plastic
in it and come out and just [ __ ]
enjoy their lives you can't do that
the attack came as a deadly battle
continuing the gaza strip escalating
tensions in the u.s
among supporters of israel and those who
back
the palestinians um
and there's also those people who are
just kind of like anti-war and they
could be like hey can we all just kind
of work this out
that whole part of the world is one of
the most beautiful places i've ever been
to in my life everybody you can't just
[ __ ] chill out
um a video cat maybe everybody needs to
do dmt
man a video capturing uh part of the
tuesday night fight shows people
in a in a caravan of cars flying
palestinian flags yelling [ __ ] you
you guys should be ashamed of yourselves
as they drive by the the restaurant i
like you guys should be ashamed of
themselves like those people who walked
out of the sushi restaurant
[ __ ] uh called the those air strikes
in
uh at one point before the attack which
later escalated to kicking and punching
a person can be heard yelling
israel kills children
um the violence in gaza and so
has killed at least 227 palestinians
including 64 children oh my god
and 12 people in israel including a
small child a teenager and a soldier
i i just i don't understand how war is
legal
um we don't know what the motivation is
that's [ __ ] hilarious
people who perpetrated the hate crime
weren't they yelling what the motivation
was
uh but we were certainly aware that what
happens in israel what happens in the
middle east does
impact us here on the ground
oh my god
anyway um
yeah my wife still eats sushi i keep
telling her it's like i would rather go
with whatever [ __ ]
[ __ ] is in cows that eat cows than eat
plastic i mean it's it's all [ __ ] bad
um hey people i'll tell you this you
know if you're actually
like really just sitting in the sadness
of whatever the [ __ ] happened to you and
then trying to work your way through it
first of all i commend you
and then secondly uh if you want to try
to work your way out of it don't read
the news
that is not a uh a way to go
um you know what i'm realizing about all
of this [ __ ] finally working my way
through myself
and i feel much better than i did
yesterday when i was in my [ __ ] days
and i creased the side of my [ __ ] car
um is
uh there's certain [ __ ] you just can't
undo
and it's never not going to be sad
and so you really
won't be able to feel things for the
rest of your life
sorry i'm just being honest
but what you can do is prevent the
people you love from going through the
same [ __ ]
you know or a lesser version of it
um by figuring out i guess you're
[ __ ]
and then that just becomes your life
work as you walk around
not feeling anything is you make sure
that they
they feel things
oh god i swear to all that [ __ ] that i
just read on the news
and the [ __ ] that i'm going through
right now is why
i don't nor will i ever believe
in a higher power that cares
and i really just don't understand like
after all of this okay now you're gonna
judge me yeah let's see how you handled
all of that down there huh
just like dude what about you what about
you creating all of these
these [ __ ] up situations here maybe
that that's what you do is what you do
is
maybe you if you start helping people
it can make you feel good like from here
on out
that you're helping people avoid feeling
the way
uh that you weren't even aware that you
felt for all of these [ __ ] years
jesus christ this is starting to feel
like a [ __ ] oprah winfrey episode
maybe that's why she just [ __ ] you
know i think that's why oprah does what
she does she went through all kinds of
horrible [ __ ] that happened to her as a
kid
and then what happens as an adult she
doesn't want people to feel pain
and next thing you know she's like you
get a car and you get a
you get a car
does that make you happy
um people i i apologize because i know
you listen to this [ __ ] thing to
[ __ ]
you know make your week go by so i'm
really not doing my job right now i
promise you
uh i am gonna i am gonna get the truck
out of the [ __ ] mud here
the psychological truck i'll figure it
out there's got to be one funny story
here
uh atlas capital playing 650 million
studio in downtown l.a
there we go a little distraction good
make some movies i can watch
how cars culture shaped the crazy cool
car uh
architecture of mid-century la okay this
is something i'm into
all right that's a gas station
february 22nd 1929.
hundreds of angelenos crowded on the
corner of 10th and hope street
in downtown l.a they had come to
celebrate the opening of a fantastical
four-story structure designed by
esteemed
architect bernard a maybach
uh oh is that like the maybach mercedes
broadcast over the radio station
kfi uh
which back then probably stood for kill
[ __ ] immigrants i love this so weird
going back in history because
look at that oh my god look at that car
and everybody's standing around but you
just know what was going on back then
uh the the event was hosted by la mayor
george cryer uh george cryer is hiding
out the movie stars dolores del rio
great name and orchestra played
standards and paul taylor's metropolitan
chorus sang popular tunes of the day
um yes we have now bananas all right
this elaborate shindig didn't mark the
the debut
debut or was it debut debut right was it
data or is it data
of a museum or a major university it was
held to celebrate a car lot
the earl c anthony corporate packard
dealership
and so i always forget
what um
if packard was gm or if it was
uh chrysler
let's see packard was an american luxury
automobile
marquee built by the packard motor
company of detroit michigan united
states the first packard automobiles
were produced in 1899
and last and the last detroit bill
packard was in 1956 when they built
the packard predictor their last
concept car company was considered the
preeminent
luxury car before world war ii and
contributed aircraft engines
for the war effort to the allied forces
owning a packard was a perceived
prestigious accolade beginning uh
being the favorite with european royalty
celebrities and corporate america
president franklin roosevelt was known
to give limousines
as gifts on several occasions that's
amazing as a politician on that meager
salary
how did he do that and surviving
examples
can be found in museums car shows but
they don't say under who i thought that
was under um
the gm or the the chevy umbrella
i've always been looking for that way
you could figure that out
because i know like like gm i believe gm
it went cadillac
buick and it was like oldsmobile pontiac
chevy something like that and somewhere
packard and desoto i don't know where
they fell into that
but what was cool back in the day was
cadillac didn't make an
entry-level cadillac a cadillac
started where buicks left off and buick
started where like oldsmobile left off
oldsmobile started where so it was like
it was just we'll just use tens of
thousands of dollars like just just
these aren't accurate prices but back in
the day you the chevy like standard like
the ford custom or whatever right
and that thing was like we'll just say
was like 10 000 bucks
and then in order to move up
you know if you wanted to buy a pontiac
you had to have money to buy a twenty
thousand dollar car
olsenbiel was thirty buick was forty
and a caddy was fifty so that's how it
was so people really could tell
how the [ __ ] you were doing in life by
the car that you drove back then like
now
i mean obviously if you buy like the top
of the line top of the line something
but i mean you look at bmw bmw
has cars you know all the way from that
little [ __ ] ice cube looking electric
car
all the way up to like the the m series
whatever seven series m is that the most
expensive one they have i don't know
or that um no that isn't it they got a
supercar there
that panda car that the rapper guy was
singing about whatever the [ __ ] you call
that car
um speaking of which the ford f-150 next
year
to 2022 is coming out it's gonna be
electric
and the first thing that i noticed it
had a ten thousand pound towing capacity
which i thought was reserved for like an
f-350
dually as far as i know right let me see
right now if we just look at the 2021
f1 50
towing capacity
uh okay oh no 5 000 to 11
300 pounds so it is the same oh all
right
i always thought that i think maybe
that's what it can
carry like a f-150 is a half-ton
an f-250 is a three-quarter ton and then
a 350 is a one-ton
as far as what it can hold i have no
idea
but that's amazing though that ford is
going to make an electric
pickup truck and i'm wondering
if people are going to go out and buy
that thing i think they're going to
and my thing is how are they going to
gear that thing
because if that thing moves like a tesla
and you're towing your [ __ ]
snowmobiles or all your landscaping
equipment and that thing [ __ ] takes
off like a jackrabbit
i would think i would think that you
would leave what was ever on the trailer
out in the [ __ ] street you'd have to
really be
like careful i had a friend of mine
recently took a tesla out for a drive
and he was like dude
[ __ ] that car that car shouldn't even be
legal it's so [ __ ] fast i was trying
to tell him i was like dude you get used
to it
you can drive that car like an old lady
if you want to
and you know speeds like anything else
it can it can save your life or it can
[ __ ] kill you
it's all how you apply it it's like
money
money can set you free or it can [ __ ]
enslave you
uh and i'm talking about being broke i'm
saying if you go
and you uh if you go out and make a
bunch of money but then you start living
a lifestyle where
you know you have to continue making a
bunch of money then what was the purpose
of making it
in the first place um this is a concept
that i'm trying
to uh i don't know i try to tell that to
younger comics i try to talk to my wife
about that stuff because you know you
know the ladies
they watch the kardashians they they
want stuff and it's just like okay
or we could just like not do that or not
buy that
and then we could just i then i don't
have to go on the road and i could just
[ __ ] hang out with you and eat a
sandwich
isn't that what life is all about
i think life is all about the times
in between [ __ ] working
now maybe it is i mean working's a good
thing but i'm just saying it's like you
know
i think loverboy said it best when they
said everybody's working for the weekend
um and with that uh that is the podcast
everybody
um please enjoy this music which i feel
should be
you know what i'm gonna just say it is
ladies and gentlemen lover boy
everybody from 1980 [ __ ] four i think
everybody is working for the weekend
uh enjoy this music put yourself in a
happy silly mood gotta love the 80s
you gotta love the 80s music all right
it wasn't like that 90s grunge where
they all came in and dumped their day on
you
people were sad in the 80s you know we
blocked it out
we did some coke we [ __ ] blew our
hair up you know look at me look how
look at my big hair
right i'm on my way i'm making it
right then the party ended
in the 90s right i'm [ __ ] sad
listen to me i think that's what i think
i've been grunge this whole podcast i'm
sorry everybody i'm back the 80s are
back on my podcast
everything isn't okay but we're gonna
act like it is
whoa all right go red sox go bruins go
[ __ ] yourselves
have a great weekend uh try to be nice
to people i will
talk to you on monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
um may 20th
yeah may 20th people keep it going for
may 20th come on
isn't she lovely may 20th 2013 how the
how the hell are you
you doing all right there huh you're
doing all right with your twinkle toes
over here
um i'm kind of in a [ __ ] up mood
um i we just got back i was on the road
with the lovely nia
for the last [ __ ] 10 days i was
really nervous about the whole thing
like 10 straight days
24 [ __ ] seven basically other than
when i was on stage running my goddamn
yap
she was gonna be uh at my side i was
like uh you know
this is gonna be bad we only had one one
major fight
one major like go [ __ ] yourself i'm
going to go become a sea captain you'd
be google be an astronaut so we can be
as far away from each other as possible
only have one of those only had one
um so we just got back to california and
we
you know taped all these shows and [ __ ]
and she was watching one they just
showed some [ __ ] jogger
some jogger got mauled to death by a
pack of pit bulls
so then i look up the story and it says
there's been like five
deadly attacks by dogs in california in
the last whatever year year and a half
and all of them
were pit bulls so i go to knee i go you
know what exactly
do we have on our hands here and she's
like well i think they were different
kind of owners
and i said oh okay
ah [ __ ] me what do i do
what do you do when you're in love with
a monster no it's not a monster
it can be it's kind of like a gun in the
wrong hands is that what it is
i don't know what it is but it [ __ ]
really made me um
made me nervous really [ __ ] made me
nervous this is kind of a creepy way to
start the podcast isn't it i usually
come on i sing a song or something right
the summer when little vegas action came
blowing in from across the sea
you wore nike flip-flops with
dark black socks down to the casino
floor
but since the mob has left and it's a
bunch of corporate
[ __ ] you can get away with that fashion
[ __ ]
oops i don't like your
white trash tattooed flabby arms
sorry i was just singing about what you
see in casinos
you know people who go to vegas can you
do me a favor can you dress up a little
bit you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
any i was gonna say and you know who you
are
all right you they don't know who they
are these [ __ ] guys who come
downstairs
like a basketball jersey on right no
[ __ ] shirt underneath it
sitting there looking at the the the
beginning or ending depending on which
way you're looking at their back of
their back acne
you know they got the shoulder zits
shorts right flip flops dark [ __ ]
black socks just standing there
i mean you know back in the day when the
mob ran it
if you didn't come downstairs with a
collared shirt on looking like a goddamn
adult
they sent you back to your room and they
said hey
welcome mate what's the matter with you
so get it out of here get it get no
[ __ ]
right they sent you back to your [ __ ]
room and you came down
all right looking like a gentleman
ladies look like ladies and the who is
dressed like
who is all right and if you were some
[ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] they just threw you out
you know how much money do we need to
make do we need to make so much [ __ ]
money
we're going to allow this [ __ ] jerk
off to be standing here like this
it was unbelievable you know everybody
you know it just
there was so many people dressed nicely
ah [ __ ] don't do this to me
sorry a little technical difficulties
there there were so many people dressed
nicely
and all it takes is just somebody like
that to just ruin the family photo
i actually took a picture of his
flip-flops and his dark socks you know
what the funny thing was is
the horror that was from the ankles down
on this guy
actually matched the casino rug
quite nicely i might add i don't know if
you guys have been to a lot of casinos
but there's some
unwritten rule that they have to have
zany carpeting
you know i don't know if it puts you in
a more festive mood as you're losing all
your [ __ ] money i don't know what it
is but
every one of those casinos not one of
them just has a nice solid color
you know an electric blue you know a red
cap
whatever an earth tone none of them
it's this confetti it's like they took
all the yarn that was left over at a
factory and they just sewed the [ __ ]
together
i don't know i know other than that i
had a great time in vegas other than
when i went down to the pool
because i go down to the pool i'm down
there it's me it's [ __ ] jay lawhead
who's been killing it in front of me
and uh the lovely nia and her cousins
and we're hanging
her and cousin i mean and we're hanging
out down the pool and they're doing the
usual [ __ ]
you know if you're a redhead and you go
down in the pool
like you you're just asking for it
people all
you know look how white you are you know
like i never noticed it's like i'm
[ __ ] around myself
i've been around myself since the 60s
the late 60s i know how white i am and
if i ever forget how white i am
there's always somebody there to remind
me
sir i don't know if you've noticed your
skin tone
what am i meditating floating up out of
my body
all right so these people i'm with go
come on come on in the pool i'm like i
don't want to go in the pool
i don't want to go in the [ __ ] pool
you know they're like why not why don't
you want to go to the pool
you know why because the [ __ ]
look at look at these people look at
them
look at them and you're you're getting
you you know would you take a bath
with all with any one of the people that
you see here these
[ __ ] just messes of human beings
there's not enough chlorine in a [ __ ]
pool to kill
whatever the [ __ ] they're dragging in
the pool you know it's like i finally
end up going to the pool
then everybody made fun of how white my
[ __ ] alabaster chest was
and then i had to stay in the shade of
the [ __ ] uh
the lifeguards chair you know
[Laughter]
you know i had a show to do i'm being a
professional i can't come out stage
later
half in the bag looking like a lobster
right i got to do my little song and
dance later on that night
so anyway so i ended up getting in the
[ __ ] pool against my what i wanted to
do
you know and then i get out of the pool
uh first of all for my age i am in
absolutely
phenomenal top shelf shape
all right i gotta tell you the the
[ __ ]
just the the [ __ ] the humanity
that i saw poolside in las vegas
the [ __ ] humanity
key word manatee
not to step step on jim gaffigan i just
realized he used to use that reference
and i'm pretty sure he used it
i can't remember how the [ __ ] he used it
but if he used it to describe
a fat pale torso not really pale but
whatever
the [ __ ] [ __ ] i saw decided that he
was dead on that
oh my god is there anything worse than
seeing a tattoo come of age
you know jesus christ if you get a
tattoo you better you better
just make the mental decision that
you're gonna p90x for the rest of your
[ __ ] life because when you don't
dude i saw this guy down at the pool all
right
he had like not only the worst tattoos
you've ever seen in your life
like the worst placement you know what i
mean
like you get one like on the side of
your arm up by your shoulder that looks
good
right on the bicep that looks good you
know
do you know somebody gets one right over
their voice box like i don't give a [ __ ]
what you have surrounding that that
leads into that part of the of
the work or the peace whatever they call
it it looks [ __ ] horrible
leg tattoos horrific horrific
so this [ __ ] jerk off he has
basically the exact sort of like tribal
thing that the rock has
except he doesn't look tribal he looks
like an accountant
you know and he doesn't work out
so just imagine if the rock was as pasty
as i was
and it never worked out in his life but
has that same tattoo that starts at the
elbow
goes up the arm over the shoulder and
covers one whole pec
but the way this guy had it done was it
didn't cover his whole pec
it came swinging in and went right above
his his man nipple
so now all of the all of that is like
colored in
so because of the pastiness of his torso
your eye is just drawn to his right
nipple
is he standing in the [ __ ] pool
my neck was sore from shaking my head at
people it was it was absolutely [ __ ]
horrific right so
so anyways um i go back up
to the uh i go back up to the hotel room
right
you know gonna make sure that i'm all
ship shaped for my goddamn show
and i put on the news and what do they
end up doing a story about
they start doing a story about the
amount of uh
fecal matter found in public pools
right after i just got out of a goddamn
pool you know and i know people always
think oh
stay away from where the kids are stay
away from the kiddie pool
right stay away from that they always
blame the [ __ ] kids well uh you know
something
after seeing what i saw pools out you
know there weren't a lot of kids in
there
but i guarantee you somebody got e coli
i know this is [ __ ] disgusting but
people you you're basically
bathing you know what's even more [ __ ]
up is is vegas
is just like you know people flying from
all over the world
you're taking a [ __ ] aids bath
you know with a shot of [ __ ] uh what
the hell is that [ __ ] that came out but
it killed people so fast that it just
burned out
everybody just ran into the woods the
[ __ ] was that [ __ ] called
ah christ i can't remember ebola
that's it with a shot of ebola
or whatever food poisoning i don't know
what it is a salmonella shower whatever
the [ __ ] you want to call it
i'm done with public pools the only pool
that i will ever swim in again
is my pool if i ever get one or the pool
of some hot chick that i want to [ __ ]
bang because i have nia's permission
that's the only way it's going to go
down
other than that you know i'll just go
i'll just go take a bath
[Laughter]
that way i'm out of the sun you know
i'll take a couple of vitamin e pills
whatever the [ __ ] it is you get from the
sun
other than skin cancer i'm done with it
you know what america needs to implement
after years and years
of calling the french people smelly you
know that's kind of like the thing
when we went over to france and saved
their ass for the second time last
century
oh wait did we do it once we did it one
time right i can't [ __ ] remember
you know i thought the spanish-american
war took place in texas
i thought it was somehow tied up and
with the alamo i had no [ __ ] idea you
know why because i never talked about it
all i talked about was a revolutionary
war we got right up to about the war of
1812 and that was it
french and indian war then they just
stopped
you know they never they never did
anything be a civil war we talked about
but that was it
spanish-american war as far as what i
remember from wikipedia
took place in like i don't know cuba
puerto rico
and like guam figure that one out
at some point you know that's one of
those books like if i ever have insomnia
i'm just gonna start reading the history
of the spanish-american war you know
i didn't realize it was an away game i
thought that that was in our building
evidently it wasn't
and it was spread out all over hale so
anyways
we've always made fun of the french
fries they smell if you ever watched uh
bugs bunny growing up
and you saw pepe le pew if you noticed
he had a french accent
you know that's the kind of [ __ ] you
couldn't get away with today because of
uh political correctness i guess they
were basically saying that you know
that they stunk but i'll tell you one
thing
that the french have when it comes to
hygiene
over americans all right is the bidet
all right i can guarantee you if i ever
go swimming in a public pool again it's
going to be in france
[Laughter]
unless there's a bunch of americans i i
know i've been over to england i never
saw a bidet over there
you know but day is basically a car wash
for your [ __ ]
and uh you know it leaves you feeling
refreshed
puts a [ __ ] smile on your face and
evidently in french you're so [ __ ]
happy you forget to put on deodorant but
i'll tell you right now you can jump in
that pool i bet they're not dead but
they're not talking about that [ __ ] over
there
right you know what's funny about this i
am 15
minutes into this podcast i just told a
15 minute [ __ ] joke
do you realize that and that can mean
only one thing
it's time for some advertising
[Laughter]
and when we come back from advertising
everybody this is what they call in the
business a teaser
um if i can figure out how to use this
tablet
i'll [ __ ] you who's this
i don't want to hear it i don't want to
hear it i don't want to hear whoever the
[ __ ] that is
let's get to the live reads here oh when
we come back from the break um
i'm going to tell you about meeting pete
rose all right here we go
all right stamps.com everybody you know
it you live it you love it
if you're not on board yet i don't know
what your problem is
all right you must just you must have a
crush on somebody who works at the post
office that's the only thing i can think
of
you know is that what it is you love the
smell of envelopes
i don't other than that i don't know why
you're going to the post office okay
because why there's nothing instant
about getting postage from the post
office
driving there parking it's a waste of
time so use stamps.com instead
instantly get postage for any letter or
package right from your desk
stamps.com is so quick and easy to use
you can buy and print official
us postage using your own computer and
printer standstop stamps.com will send
you a digital scale that automatically
calculates the exact postage you need
they'll even help you decide the best
class of mail based on your needs
not my needs your needs oh steve jobs
stop it with this iphone here
sorry about that anyways there's no
guesswork plus it's convenient
take care of your mailing and shipping
whenever you need to 24 7 right from
your desk you'll never have to go to the
post office again or do it from the
comfort of your own home like i do
i use stamps.com to send out all my dvds
i've never had a problem i absolutely
loved it i hated going to the post
office i've never been happier when it
comes to mail
right now use my last name bur burr for
this special offer
no risk trial plus a 110 bonus offer
that includes a digital scale and up to
55 dollars free postage
uh don't wait go to stamps.com before
you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bur
b-u-r-r that's stance.stamps.com enter
bur
um what else do i got oh jesus where's
whiz
i gotta go to e-voice now i'm using a
tablet for the first time everybody
here we go e-voice e-voice is the reason
you're gonna make more money in 2013.
you know you thought you were gonna rob
a bank no reason to do that
just start using e-voice and you will
make more money in 2013.
when your customers call you have your
own toll-free number
profess professional greeting dial by
name directory and more you'll sound
like a fortune 500 company and blow away
your competitors
evoid lets you get give out one number
that rings wherever you are
the beach the bar doesn't matter you'll
sound like you're at the office
you got to go to evoice dot com and use
the promo code bill
evoice even takes all your voicemails
transcribes them and sends
sends to you ins and transcribes them
and sends to you instantly as a text or
email
sorry so you can e-voice
so you can check e-voice mails before
the meeting ends and not look rude
e-voice is only 10 bucks a month right
now listeners to my podcast can get a
free trial of e-voice for 30 days
stop what you're doing hit pause set up
your e-voice free trial
and see what i'm talking about it's a
great way to support my podcast
my podcast in an easy way to make more
money this year
go to evoice dot com promo code bill
that's evoice dot com
promo code bill or just go to the
podcast page on billboard.com
and click the e-voice banner right now
all right
good lord i have like i just really have
issues with reading out loud some weeks
yes some weeks because i've been doing
better
recently okay i know you [ __ ] are gonna
give me [ __ ]
some weeks what about every week
lol shaking my head
oh here's another thing for twitter hack
when people when people
begin to joke with in other news
you know that weekend update staple from
1986 on snl
you know blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah
all right that's your joke right class
it's probably the worst description ever
now go [ __ ] yourself so anyway so i'm
walking back to the hotel
and i walk by this sports members i'm
back in vegas by the way
all right are you with me we're out of
the [ __ ] pool
and now i'm walking through the little
mall there and i see this sports
memorabilia place and i see pete rose is
going to be there
like the guy's gonna be here in an hour
i'm like i gotta meet this [ __ ] guy
it's [ __ ] pete rose
and i'm looking all the baseballs he
signs it's hilarious he signs it hits
uh like 4256
steroids zero pete rose hit king
i thought that was the [ __ ] um
so anyways i'd seen him signing there
before and the line was too long and i
didn't feel like
waiting so this time me and lawhead who
does
an amazing impression of him breaking ty
cobb's record
the entire thing him standing on first
base
hitting the ball standing on first place
waving to the crowd
gradually trying to fight off tears
hugging his son and breaking down he
does the whole
[ __ ] thing um he does it at the rose
bowl
after cooking a delicious meal but
anyway so i'm hanging out with tim
and you can have you buy all this
memorabilia and pete rose will uh will
sign it for you
so they had two photos and one
was pete rose like
sliding headfirst into third base in the
1975 world series
when he beat my boston red sox and
another photo that i saw
in the collection was pete rose in the
1976 world series
where they beat the yankees once again
sliding headfirst
into third base batting helmet who knows
where it went
it always flew off it seemed between
first and second base
um so i'm like oh my god that's per i
got to get
i got to get both of those right so my
whole thing is i want him to write on
the red sox one
bill i'm sorry pete rose and then on the
yankee one
bill you're welcome pete rose right so i
bring it up to him
great guy hey how you doing and all that
type of thing so i tell them i go okay i
go a big red sox fan this is you beating
the red sox this is you beating the
yankees so
on this one just right bill i'm sorry
and he immediately looks at me and he
goes i'm not
[Laughter]
i [ __ ] died laughing i loved it he
still had that competitive thing you
know
and i was like i know you're not i go
say you're not that's funny or whatever
and he didn't he still wrote it and then
just write you know
you know you're welcome on the other one
and he actually wrote uh
he wrote bill i'm sorry on one uh pete
rose 1975 world series mvp
and on the other one he wrote uh
bill you're welcome pete rose and then
he wrote reds
four yankees zero something about a
sweep or something like that in fact
when i brought up the yankees
i said yeah but you beat the yankees in
1976 he goes
and immediately goes swept their asses
it's [ __ ] great
um so anyways i got to meet him we could
shot the [ __ ] with him for a second shot
the [ __ ] with the greatest hitter of all
time
you know i asked him who was uh who's
the toughest guy he ever faced
all right i'm gonna pause here you gonna
guess who do you think
it was a guy from the 60s who do you
think
huh what are you guessing bob gibson
that's a good guess don drysdale another
good guess
steve calton it was actually sandy kofx
i was like really sandy koufax then he
made this motion
of like the ball just [ __ ] dropping
off a cliff he did it with both hands
like the guy could get it breaking
either way and
uh i don't know i actually talked about
the red sox he actually like
still watches baseball he's totally
[ __ ] into it
and uh i think at first he thought me
and jay were a couple of creeps that he
could tell that we
we really you know looked up to him and
wanted to talk baseball and he was
[ __ ]
you know just totally warmed up man cool
as hell so if you ever get a chance
and don't be a [ __ ] like that little
weasel that brought that [ __ ] up all
right everybody knows he been on
baseball enough already
you know they didn't let him into the
hall of fame
he signed a memorabilia at a casino he's
paying the price
you know you realize how small that is
like they actually had a baseball there
it was all in black that he signs i'm
sorry i bet on baseball
pete rose and i'm just like ugh jesus
christ
you bring that ball up to him kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] would do that
oh who's kidding who half the people on
twitter um
anyways oh you know what [ __ ] blows
it doesn't blow it was actually an
awesome sporting uh experience
but uh i don't know some of you guys who
follow me on twitter or whatever
last week i was in boston
and uh i'm if you listen to last week's
podcast i mentioned that i was going to
that bruins maple leafs game seven
and uh i did get in i was there i went
with this comedian doug signier
boston guy who came up from up from new
york we went to the game i had a good
feeling i thought we were gonna win it
and uh i gotta be honest with you
you know we look good for the first two
minutes and then all of a sudden it was
all leafs after that
and at three to one
i i was convinced we were gonna lose oh
my god that's it that's it we scored two
goals that's our limit they just scored
the third
you know the leafs are playing great
hockey they totally got this game in
hand so
you know and then they went up four to
one and that's when
the first like wave of bruins fans
started leaving
like seven eight minutes left i forget
what happened and like people were
leaving and leaf fans were moving down
all right now it's not like i'm sitting
there going you know i gave him [ __ ] for
leaving
i was yelling where you going the [ __ ]
but my [ __ ] was more
we have to stay because i hate when the
other team's fans take over your
building
you know what i mean and get to
celebrate and kind of [ __ ] dance in
your living room
so after three to one i was convinced we
were gonna lose so but the only reason
why i was still there
was because uh i was there to basically
give maple leaf fans dirty look
when they beat us so they'd have to tone
down their celebration
and also to give a bad description of to
the cops if somebody threw something at
him
you know unless it was something major
and really hurt him
um so that's it so i'd like to thank my
mother for teaching me to never leave
you always stay you never leave the game
until it's over and we stayed there and
all of a sudden it was four to two
blue cheek scored then it was four to
three four to four the [ __ ] place was
going insane and i was actually nervous
that um you know in the end of
regulation that
was giving toronto a time to regroup
almost like when you're in a fight
you know you see a fighter and he's got
the guy in the ropes and all of a sudden
saved by the bell i almost felt like it
was like that and i just had this i had
this
gnawing feeling that they would have
come out and score a quick one and all
that excitement would have been for
nothing but fortunately
uh bergeron scored and i have to tell
you as far as sporting events that i've
ever been to
that one is a close second to uh i went
to the super bowl when the patriots beat
the rams for our first super bowl
championship it was unbelievable
my condolences to the leaf fans man i
think you guys are [ __ ] awesome fans
and uh i wouldn't wish what happened to
you on anybody other than montreal
canadian fans for the simple fact that
they [ __ ] deserve it
uh you know what's funny though
leaf fans are really hated they're
really hated i don't know why
i've never understood that like how you
can like have that level of no
championships
i mean that they're they're going on
46 years so it's 47
seasons they're coming up on 50 [ __ ]
years a half a century
and not winning [ __ ] and people still
hate him
i don't know why i don't you know i'm
gonna have to ask some canadian people
what what the [ __ ] deal is with that
because i would think that they would
hate montreal fans more but it seems i
don't know
i was surprised maybe they do hate
montreal fans more i don't know but i
was surprised
at the level of hatred like the emails
that i was getting from other canadians
about how much they hate [ __ ] toronto
leaf maple leaf fans the ones that came
to the uh fleet center were cool as hell
you know and uh so whatever so now we're
into the next round of the [ __ ]
brewings
here we go brewings here
that's what it used to be that after
[ __ ] the rangers won it in 1994
and that let's go rangers became so
iconic that [ __ ]
rhythm took over everything so now
whenever people go
let's go bruh wins i can never fully
give my heart into that [ __ ] uh
that chant because i'm always thinking
that's the rangers chant we were always
here we go bruins here we go they were
always let's go rangers but like that
whole
that whole cadence has taken over
everything
which the funniest one is yankee fans
because they used to go 19 18
and then when that was over they for
some reason
you needed four syllables they went they
took a
fourth like syllable chant
and they try to cram i mean uh elongate
the third
they basically they went from 1918 to
boston
sucks but they kept the same rhythm so
they go
boston sucks
oh those [ __ ] hero eating jackasses
um why would you be like [ __ ] you boston
i mean something that
fit you know why because they're not
that smart
um anyways
but anyway you know what's the best
thing about [ __ ] being back in boston
because i
i watched the uh i watched the red sox
game went out to get some pizza and i
just walked out
it just was so [ __ ] nice this is the
biggest thing i miss about
living in massachusetts is just walking
into a sports bar
or a [ __ ] pizza place and the game i
want to watch
is on and everybody in there is for the
team that i like
i moved away from boston in 1995 and
it's like i've been
behind enemy lines here coming up on 20
[ __ ] years
and i'm exhausted i'm like i've said
this before on the podcast i'm like
i'm like a sports like donnie brosco
you know somebody sent me a [ __ ]
tweet today they go hey bill uh now that
you live in l.a uh
are you a kings fan now or do you still
have loyalty to the bruins
and i that is i can't even relate to
that [ __ ] question that's such a dumb
question i don't understand how people
how you root for a team
your whole [ __ ] life and then you
move somewhere else you're like well i
guess i'll root for these guys now
you know i don't hate the kings i mean
they sucked my whole life coming up
so we never ran into them we always ran
to the edmonton oilers as far as people
out west
they used to [ __ ] kick our ass so uh
but even then i didn't hate him
i hated the canadians i hated the sabers
i hated
hartford
the nordics i didn't mind for some
reason but that was the adams division
back then so i
really didn't like them i didn't like
the devils
[ __ ] islanders were always tough
islanders were tough
jesus they were tough back then in the
early 80s
obviously they were in the middle of a
[ __ ] dynasty so um
yeah i so the person who asked me that i
don't hate the uh
i'm not a fan i'm actually a fan like i
like the way they play i like their
their
uh franchise the same way i like you
know i'm a fan of like the devil raised
or something like that but uh
until they they didn't let people say
devil anymore
you know like tampa needed another
reason to make funny
fun of them you know what i mean i think
the name our baseball team's too evil
i don't mind the fish part but the other
part i just i just don't like i don't
eat devil's food cake
and i love dessert um you know it
reminds me of last night oh big first of
all
big thank you to uh the mirage
casino for having me out there um and
everybody who showed up i had
so much fun the two shows that i did out
there and
they had me you know i took a picture of
it
and i know you guys are gonna [ __ ] all
over me you guys always figure out a
[ __ ] way
to [ __ ] all over me but i don't give a
[ __ ] it's a big moment in my life so i'm
up on one of those
main marquees out there they had a big
stupid [ __ ] redhead
right up there you know it was [ __ ]
awesome i was playing this
theater and um
it was great it was packed both shows
signed some dvds took some pictures
had a great [ __ ] time you know
you know i did i only gambled once i bet
on the preakness
i came down i was watching the penguins
um
senators game the one where [ __ ]
crosby had the hat trick right out of
the gate
and uh i was sitting there with lawhead
you know nursing a beer because i had a
show that night
and i'm watching and in front of us
these guys were betting the horses and i
gotta tell you something
there's no gamblers are funnier than
people who bet the [ __ ] horses man
they are hilarious they get so [ __ ]
into it as they're coming down the home
stretch i stopped watching the hockey
game the hockey game was on the giant
one
they're watching it on these little
screens and like these [ __ ]
degenerate gambling
cubicles and they got their rolled up
programs and they're hitting the table
just go come on you sex come on you're
six come on you six
hit them don't say they literally go
with the horse and go come on you six
come on you sex come on you said come on
you're saying
it's just hit him hit him head up this
[ __ ] guy yelled in the casino
beat that horse
[Music]
you can understand i'm living out here
right in [ __ ] tinseltown
most liberal place ever all right peter
has a goddamn parade out here every
[ __ ] three seconds so just to hear
that
beat that horse i was [ __ ] dying
laughing
even though i love horses and if i ever
owned one my dreams to own a horse and
never ride it
you know keep that [ __ ] pure i don't
even want to break it
so it allows me to get on its [ __ ]
back
my stupid booze weight sitting on his
back as it walks me up a hill
even though if it wanted to it could
just kick me with its back foot and
knock me out forever
there's something sad about that so
anyways
so i go down there the next day with
lawhead so we put money on the preakness
i think i remember little [ __ ] even
one of the horses we bet wasn't in the
rate wasn't in the race from [ __ ] the
second it started
and then my other going i bet was it
horse number it wasn't three
something with gold in it i can't
[ __ ] remember was in second place
until they came around the clubhouse
turn and then that was it
uh but the [ __ ] place was jam-packed
and people were going
crazy for like a minute and a half or
whatever it is
it's just they go nuts the second
they're let out
and then then that dies down and then
they're coming around the first turn
there's this murmur there you go they go
get on the rail get on the rail
you know and then is it coming down the
back stretch that
[ __ ] [ __ ] when they come down and
down the stretch they come the place
is going [ __ ] crazy
everybody's screaming there was this one
guy i watched him he lost six races in a
[ __ ] row
so and i didn't bet any of the races
this guy was like the
the mush in a bronx tale and i'm looking
at he's the guy who yelled beat that
horse right
so i'm looking at him because i bet the
preakness and i see him and his family
sitting behind me
he's got this big shitty grin on his
face and i bet i think horse number
three in horse number eight
and he's got this big shitty grin on his
face and he turned around
and he looks basically over my head he
looks back at his family
and he holds up number seven and he's
smiling and nodding i'm thinking right
there i go well that [ __ ] horse isn't
winning
if he said three or eight i swear to god
if i had any backbone i would have tore
up my ticket like [ __ ] chairs palm
and terry just
just go home guys it's over um
so anyways let's get on to [ __ ]
reading something for this week i had a
really
um interesting email from somebody
i don't know how to uh
i really don't know how to what the hell
is this
this is going to be brutal this week
because you know what these guys are
finally working on my house and i don't
have internet
because the room that they did they
[ __ ] yank the thing out of the wall
all right here we go
helping an ugly friend do you have an
ugly friend sure
we all do here we go dear william burr
um thanks for doing the podcast
thank you um one of my good friends is
ugly
i'll say it outright god bless his heart
he's 26
short disproportionate face
i don't know what that means uh skinny
with a gut slowly forming oh god
receding hairline jesus
and worst of all he doesn't take care of
his teeth
yeah wow jesus [ __ ] christ
all i thought of there was clint howard
um over the past couple years
he's gotten more and more bitter about
life i believe it's due to his
insecurity about his looks and
attracting women
he has a great degree really well-paying
job
good sense of humor and can talk to the
ladies
however he lacks the killer instinct
needed to close the deal
meaning he gets friend zoned with every
girl that is possibly interested
which is very few well you're kind of
talking out of both
sides of your mouth if you're saying
he's great with the women but he just
can't close the deal
why there are only a few women
interested in them what are you gonna
say see the first paragraph we decide to
[ __ ]
you basically described a troll um
myself and close friends have been
subtly pushing him to work out clean his
teeth
eat healthy healthy etc but he gets very
offended whenever we suggest anything
he seems to be sent on a path of
thinking he's going to have to wait
until his 40s before women will be
desperate enough
to ignore his looks and date him for a
successful career
uh this type of attitude is starting to
affect his friendships he's getting
bitter and defensive
bitter defensive and confrontational
nobody likes an angry troll
they really don't okay if you're going
to go the troll route you know
you got to be at the very least affable
you know working your way towards jolly
i would think
maybe put on a silly hat build some toys
i don't know um as his friend how can i
help him get
off this path and boost his confidence
to get that killer instinct and
confidence
that the ladies love even if you're if
even if you're ugly thanks for the
advice and go [ __ ] yourself
um ps shout out to the beautiful city of
boston i was there last year for a
hockey tournament and can't wait to go
back
pss [ __ ] your ruins i've lost two years
of my life due to the stress of the
the maple leaf series oh jesus god must
have sent that before
it was over um
all right so what do you say to this guy
ah wow well i don't know him but at some
point you're just gonna have to [ __ ]
lay it on the line
and say it to him and say like look you
know something
you're just like me all right you want
to have fun
you want to go sow your oats as they say
and then you want to find
love and get married and start a family
correct
you know you got to brush your [ __ ]
teeth
i don't know how to how do you go into
it slowly like this is
no matter how you come at it when
somebody's defensive
that there's there's no way to come at
them without burning up in the
atmosphere
of their [ __ ] bitterness during
reentry
how do you do it i would wait to the
next time he says something bitter
and or defensive or something like that
and just look at him and be like listen
dude you're your own worst enemy
all right life is a horse race and
you're shooting yours in the back
of the head before the [ __ ] gate even
opens then you're walking around the
track with mud on your shoes
you know wondering why i don't know why
you're [ __ ] some other horse racing
thing that i don't know [ __ ] about
i picked the wrong metaphor you know
what i mean just wait till he's being a
[ __ ]
i remember one time i i knew this guy he
was just negative as [ __ ] hell
and you'd say hey you know something if
you keep doing this maybe this will
happen and then you always be like yeah
you know with my luck
the [ __ ] piano fell on my head and i
got sick of it and then finally be like
yeah you know well you know if you think
that way that's probably going to happen
and only said it one time and he never
talked that way again
he's still negative but i didn't have to
deal with that [ __ ]
i don't know what to do with this guy
like um
you might you might have to [ __ ]
channel patrice o'neill
god rest his soul patrice o'neill would
have sat this dude down and would have
said
n word what the [ __ ] are you doing
look at yourself you know
you got a [ __ ] up face you're losing
your goddamn hair
at the very least brush your [ __ ]
teeth
get some [ __ ] better clothes what's
wrong he i can't do i can't do what he
would have done
he would have been able to do it he
would have hurt the guy's feelings so
bad
while helping him to become a better
person at the same time
you might you're gonna have to come up
with your own [ __ ] version of that
you know i
i i don't know what what do you do when
somebody just stops brushing their teeth
you're just tapping out on humanity
and you're saying he's smart he has a
degree
he's not one of those is anything worse
than somebody really smart with bad
[ __ ] hygiene
you know those people they're so [ __ ]
smart they you know but
they show up they got like sleep in
their eye
oh god dude bad teeth is a goddamn
deal breaker you know
jesus [ __ ] christ you know what's
funny i'm disgusted with this guy don't
you don't
you get me fighting you you're just
gonna quit
[ __ ] [ __ ] i was born with orange
hair did i quit
i got great teeth did i ever stop
brushing
no i didn't
i got second and third degree burns when
i went out in the sun
you know then i stopped flossing i
didn't quit [ __ ] moping around you
ugly [ __ ] you get yourself some
scope
and listerine and a [ __ ] scrub brush
you go to a goddamn dentist you get your
[ __ ] teeth clean
all right when you hit on a woman you
stay on it you keep those plates
spreading
always have a condom always be ready
what time is it it's right do something
like that i don't know what the [ __ ] to
tell you
that [ __ ] there's nothing that annoys
me more than watching somebody just quit
tell him that tell him stop being such a
[ __ ] baby
this [ __ ] eight-year-old sewing
together his goddamn
shirts he's probably toddlers making the
toothbrushes that he's not even using oh
poor [ __ ] baby
you know you don't look like john
davidson who gives a [ __ ]
brush your teeth shave your [ __ ] head
down
all right go to the gym give yourself a
fighting chance
stop treating yourself like you're the
pirates
you know or running yourself like the
[ __ ] pirates do what did i do to this
goddamn thing
all right sorry man i just there's just
something that really [ __ ] gets me
about people who do that [ __ ] who just
[ __ ] quit
there's nothing worse than that unless
you really just truly suck at something
like you know like you guys hear i sing
i'm terrible but it's funny because it's
the podcast but if i was actually trying
to sing
professionally that's one thing you
really should quit
and [ __ ] do something else for just
just for your fellow man
you know
but you're just just just a quit you're
just gonna quit
i'm legitimately disgusted with that
person i never met before i don't know
what to tell you
i want an [ __ ] ugh
[ __ ] any gets bitter you know what that
reminds me of some reason there was fun
one time i was doing a show and there
was somebody in the front row that was
mentally challenged so
there's no way i'm [ __ ] with this guy
and then i get on stage and the kid's a
[ __ ]
he starts [ __ ] heckling me you know
and every time i don't say anything back
he gets a little more [ __ ] confident
and then finally i was just like you
know what i came up with the [ __ ] i said
to him the crowd pulled back and i'm
like you know what [ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] this guy they're just like
everybody else
okay some of them are [ __ ] and this is
a great example
so [ __ ] you buddy
i kind of kept it at that it was really
a fight oh man that guy [ __ ] annoyed
me
i was doing some hellgig the first time
i lived out here in l.a i'm staying at
some [ __ ] mexican restaurant
i'm getting [ __ ] heckled by this kid
all right
i mean what i'm doing living in l.a i'm
going through that [ __ ] [ __ ] but
you know what i didn't quit
i brushed my teeth before that [ __ ]
show
[Music]
dude when you when you just don't brush
your teeth you just tapped out
you're just saying [ __ ] it why won't
this wait a minute
why won't this thing [ __ ] load
yeah jesus christ
you know you guys hear me battling this
[ __ ] every week do i [ __ ] quit this
loading how do i make it go back
oh i was doing so well and all i had to
do was read a couple more and i was done
what if i shut it off and then i turn it
back
on again what happened ah jesus christ
i swear how do these things make your
[ __ ] life easier
can somebody please explain it to me how
it makes it easier oh sure
it's easier to go shopping or find out
you know what your [ __ ] neighbor
jerks off to but other than that
how does it make your [ __ ] life
easier for someone like me
hey nia
i know she hears me and that's the thing
that slowly kills you in a relationship
i know she [ __ ] hears me and i know
she hears the panic in my [ __ ] voice
and i know she knows that i need her and
she just go i gotta hit pause god
[ __ ] damn it hang on a second every
[ __ ] week
all right i'm back i'm back here we go
uh hulu plus everybody
hulu plus everybody um you've tried
streaming hit shows on your pc on
hulu.com
now it's time to start your free trial
of exclusive content in your living room
and on your mobile devices on hulu plus
with hulu plus you get a tote you get
total control
to watch thousands of shows wherever you
want whenever you want
uh use hulu plus on connected tvs
game consoles blu-ray players roku
apple tv pc or watch from anywhere on
your smartphone or tablet
on demand at all times jesus christ i'm
gonna get this this is phenomenal
and with hulu plus you can binge on full
seasons watch your favorite current
shows
and even full series runs of classic tv
shows it's endless
are you serious you know i usually just
read these things this is actually
impressive as hell
they've got community modern family
southpack
snl monday night raw the man show jimmy
kimmel family guy and more
feel free to swap this out with shows on
the list
i guess i wasn't supposed to read that
um hulu plus is only 7.99 per month
but right now they're offering an
extended free trial of hulu plus
that is only available to podcast
listeners take control of your tv
watching experience yeah you don't need
networks anymore you create your own
network you watch it when you want
where you want and on whatever the hell
you want other than the back of your
hand you're going to be good
go to the podcast page at billboard.com
and click on the hulu plus banner
for your extended free trial or go to
huluplus.com
bill again click the hulu plus banner on
the podcast page at billbird.com
or go to huluplus.com bill
um that's phenomenal that is absolutely
phenomenal
i wonder if i can watch nfl and uh nhl
games there
oh here's some of the shows available
downton abbey
it's not downtown the vampire uh diaries
the game new girl i was on that
the office glee the mindy project parks
and rec
late night with jimmy fallon
wow they got everything you know what
that's pretty that's pretty damn cool
i like it all right next thing here uh
what do we got
legalzoom.com everybody america was
built by innovators and dreamers
people like edison henry ford and steve
jobs
but it's the inventors and entrepreneurs
all around us people
like you know what [ __ ] that i'm i'm
doing a different read i'm not saying
steve jobs
i'm not saying it all right i'm sick of
this guy getting credit like he [ __ ]
did everything
oh my god these baby boomers are so
obnoxious
let's start over again legalzoom.com
legalzoom.com america was built america
was built by innovators and dreamers
people like edison henry ford and albert
einstein
but it's the inventors and entrepreneurs
all around us people like you
that make it make america bill gates
make america such a great country
aaron spelling this month legal
legalzoom celebrates
innovations by helping you launch your
dream apply for a patent to secure your
invention
register your trademark to protect your
products and services incorporate
or form an llc and launch your business
dream
um just call or visit legalzoom.com
and they'll take care of you from start
to finish they've already helped about
a million businesses get started and
they got them started right
uh celebrate innovation with
legalzoom.com and for a limited time get
a special price
on trademark copyright and patent
applications by using the referral code
burr at checkout protect your creations
and launch your dream at legalzoom.com
legalzoom can provide self-help services
at your
specific direction or they can connect
you to an attorney
but they are not a law firm don't forget
to use that referral code
bur b-u-r-r all right there we go
back to the podcast yep
all right experience with the threesome
all right firstly congrats on the
podcast love you [ __ ]
um anyways in a recent podcast you
mentioned a guy who wants to bang
another chick
in front of his wife then you ask if
someone's got some good stories no no no
she wanted him to do it oh by the way
somebody else gave me a great insight to
that
which was uh that his wife or girlfriend
did the same thing said she wanted to
see him
have sex with another woman and it
turned out that she was trying to lessen
her guilt because she already [ __ ]
around on him
so uh you know it's a tangled web being
weaved here
out of the [ __ ] he is um after
countless efforts of hitting on this
after countless efforts of hitting on
this chick in my class i found out that
she was
she was engaged so i gave it a rest not
long after she started hinting sexual
stuff
all the time getting a little too
comfortable with the touching
i bet a [ __ ] was [ __ ] like this and
[ __ ] myself
over to bang some random chick who turns
out to be a psycho at least a couple of
times
oh so you're sitting there going i think
this girl's giving me sexual vibes but
uh
i don't want to be an idiot and [ __ ]
where i eat is that what you're saying
well you're not here to tell me either
way so that's what i'm gonna think so
anyways he goes i started to question
her about her man and what she really
wants if she's just being a tease
she said she suggested to her fiance to
have a threesome
with another chick from class now she
wants
the two dude type of deal tag teaming
double penetration of whatever else you
want to call it dude right there that's
not your wife
okay that is a free [ __ ] spirit
okay you bang her and then you hand her
backpack and you let her continue
walking down the road
with that little sauce pan clean clean
the pots and pans clinking off the back
anyways he goes i can't say it was
comfortable
so i had to lay some ground rules no eye
contact between the guys
no sword crossing etc etcetera
dude i gotta tell you something that
what is in it for the
as a guy to have a [ __ ] two on one
with another dude although i know one
i know one guy who i actually understood
it because
they would be doing the rotisserie with
some girl and they would well
you know she can't look at them
obviously because she's busy
and what they would do is they would try
to make each other laugh
now to me that that's [ __ ] hilarious
um and unless you're the woman you never
want to hear somebody just go in the
middle of [ __ ] having sex with you i
guess
um are you laughing at my eyes about a
week later
let's get back to the thing here about a
week later chick invited me
um to the house i'm sorry i'm having
more trouble than usual
reading this i keep touching this
[ __ ] tablet thing here and [ __ ] just
keeps popping up
i don't know how to get rid of it all
right i think we're back to normal here
so he goes about a week later the chick
invited me to the house to prepare
a presentation and ask the dude if he
was okay with everything
that happened he said
well she let me have it with another
chick so it's totally fair
oh okay so you guys haven't done it yet
so did you guys come in there and
dressed in like power suits with like a
[ __ ] little
briefcases he's sitting at the end of a
long table
you know with his elbows on the table
and all fingertips touching each other
and uh how do you plan to make uh my
dick some money this week
anyways he goes so i asked if he was
okay with it
his eyes started getting all watery and
face got red
and that vein in the forehead starts
popping
he says it [ __ ] him up every time he
thinks about it
but it also turned him onto a whole
different level i asked whether he still
want to be married to her
he said he doesn't know and excused
himself
i asked what her vision behind this
whole [ __ ] was and apparently
she takes pleasure to see him jealous
and can't do anything about it
she likes the whole watching him
watching her being [ __ ] by a man or a
woman
she doesn't want to hurt him so she lets
him in on the action but she loves this
swinging type of [ __ ] a lot more
oh my god so wait a minute see you did
it
right dude you're writing you're leaving
out words here and you're making a dumb
guy sound even worse here
let me go back about a week later chick
invited me to the house to prepare
a presentation and i asked to do it if
he was okay with everything
that happened all my fault i read it
wrong or i wasn't listening my
as i was talking because i was so
nervous about [ __ ] up the next
sentence
oh my god
dude what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
that you went back
you know like you're doing some
follow-up survey
this whole thing is weird so when he
goes
well let's just say things were awesome
in my shoes but i felt a little bad that
they broke up dude you know what you did
you just saved a [ __ ] soul
the soul that the two of them were gonna
[ __ ] make okay
that soul will go into a [ __ ]
different person
i don't i don't know how it works i'm
not a religious guy but yeah you just
stopped a kid from being brought into
the world
by uh by a couple of [ __ ]
people who need to go to therapy i think
i guess i'm judging i don't know what
those aren't parents anyways funny thing
is he still
come he still goes over to [ __ ] her and
another partner
sometimes even another couple partners
swapping thing
basically swinger [ __ ] buddies oh yeah
well you opened pandora's box
now no pun intended now it's no biggie
to him
he goes i wouldn't call them freaks
there are some people but this type of
[ __ ]
doesn't usually work out for the best in
relationships let alone a marriage
excuse my bad grammar and poor
descriptive skills
well you know what you should have
started your email with that so everyone
wouldn't think
that it was me wow man i've never been
involved in any any [ __ ] like that i
never had a threesome or anything
i think i could have had two i'd said
this before one of them
i was so young and stupid i was actually
annoyed with the other girl going why
won't she [ __ ] leave
so i can bang her friend you know i
didn't get that she was
lingering around that one kills me
because they were both [ __ ] great
looking
and then the other one was was a layup
but one was
[ __ ] gorgeous and the other one
looked like a goddamn
refrigerator
she was like [ __ ] six to one of those
rich people refrigerators you know what
i mean that's just built into the
[ __ ] wall
that's what she looked like and it's
just like i you know
would need one of those like some rock
climbing [ __ ] to [ __ ] handle that one
so i
i gracefully bowed out of that
um yeah that's that's an entire let me
ask you this sir do you live in atlanta
i always get that [ __ ] freak vibe in
atlanta
anyways here we go philosophy workshop
i'm doing a
philosophy workshop this summer called
rape jokes and other effects dude what
is with all this
[ __ ] babbling about rape jokes
i swear to [ __ ] christ i go to comedy
clubs all the time
like you're making it seem like every
five seconds somebody talks about it
you know these [ __ ] idiot bloggers
blogging about what kind of [ __ ] joke
do you understand how [ __ ] dumb that
is
that's like if you played guitar and you
start blogging about what chords people
should and shouldn't use good [ __ ]
it's not even frustrating it's just it's
bizarre
it's really bizarre and i've yet to see
anybody i don't know
anybody that's kind of doing anything or
who's considered funny that's really
going around telling people what they
should talk about i was why don't you
work on your own act
you know if you don't like rape jokes
don't do any
i don't like country music i would never
say don't do [ __ ] country music
it's bizarre the whole [ __ ] the whole
thing is just [ __ ] i'm going to stop
talking about this because i'm just
going to add fuel to the fire
um let's just blow through these dumb
questions here can people be
inappropriately offended if so how do we
draw the line between a pro
this is so [ __ ] stupid don't go to a
comedy club
oh my god i went to the pool and i got
wet is there a way to make the pool
drier
um how wet is too wet is being offended
a moral response
if what kind of response if you're
morally wrong someone
it's appropriate for you to feel guilt
who is is this one of these bloggers who
wrote this i find that the whole thing
unbelievably childish and silly i'm not
even going to give it any
[ __ ] time of day what about chickens
what about the chickens who died
and you're talking about eating a
chicken blt
um anyways plowing ahead here
i met girl last week of school hey bill
this past weekend i made out with this
girl i've been talking to at school
since then we've been talking nonstop
and i really like her
and i think she likes me oh isn't this
nice
but in a little more than a week we will
both be graduating
she lives in philly and i live right
outside of new york well you can kiss
that [ __ ] goodbye
sorry that was me all right she's really
cool and different than all the other
girls at school i'm just wondering what
you think i should do
this upcoming week is senior his senior
week you know what i shouldn't have said
that you actually like this girl i
apologize
i'm an idiot um this up i'm gonna treat
it with respect
for the rest of this for the rest of
this [ __ ] email
um this upcoming week is senior week a
week full of drinking and non-stop
partying until graduation
i know we're gonna be hanging out all
week and i just want to get your
thoughts
on what i should do after graduation i
really like her she's pretty smart
and is into a lot of the same stuff i am
anywho thanks for everything
big fan of you and the podcast and i
just watched stand up guys hilarious oh
thank you
uh that sound you make when you get shot
made me laugh so hard yeah
got shot in the head you're not gonna
make a graceful noise
um all right where are we going here
um what are we doing you know what sir
you're at that time in your life
where you have to figure this [ __ ] out
um
you can't ask someone as old and as
jaded as me because you heard what i
said right out
of the gate it was [ __ ] insensitive
and it was mean and it had nothing to do
with you or the wonderful woman
that you're dating that had to do with
me and the train wreck
of my [ __ ] dating career all right so
there's your lesson
here's your lesson something that i
learned uh tom papa taught me this one
anytime he said anytime i make a big
decision in my life and i tell people
about it
i realize that most of the time their
reaction
has nothing to do with what i'm doing it
has everything to do with them
so i say look if you like this girl
you know it's the long distance thing is
really hard
you're going to go to they're both going
you guys are both going to different
colleges i mean it's like a [ __ ]
nightclub
and just all these single people
like carl you're never going to be in a
greater nightclub than college
and it's just a shame that when you're
going through it you don't realize it
it's just you have the pick of the
litter
you know but the problem is is you
you're you're i don't know
you want all these experiences you're
just getting out from underneath your
parents and they they should really
have college like when you're 25 26
all right and just make it illegal to
get married until then you know
you just kind of have a good time figure
out what the [ __ ] you want then you go
to college and you got this you pick up
all these [ __ ] people
maybe not 26 by then you're a little bit
i don't know it's just everybody kind of
in the prime of their life
before they get jaded and that type of
[ __ ] so i i would you know what i would
do sir i would follow your heart
that's my advice and i wouldn't listen
to old grizzled [ __ ] like myself all
right
good luck t i hope it all works out um
yeah you follow your heart you'll never
be wrong you can still get hurt but
you're not wrong
because everybody hurts sorry um wife is
getting heavy
oh jesus dear bildo
i didn't get that at first
ah [ __ ] i didn't get that that's [ __ ]
hilarious
i didn't i read it and it didn't make
sense till it came out of my mind i saw
doe d.o.e like do we dear i was like
what is he calling me a [ __ ]
bambi or something i didn't get it oh my
god that's [ __ ] funny
um i love the podcast you stand up
you're the
the best guest on rogue and yada yada
all right i'm a 26 year old
fella from maine due to tie the knot in
october
with my lady of seven years and we have
a great relationship and are very happy
well congratulations sir you've hit the
lottery you're living in god's country
you know you got yourself a great woman
you got a great start here
where is the left turn coming everybody
let's continue reading
she's smart and didn't take [ __ ] from no
one
she is uh stuck with me supported me
through my oxy
cotton addiction of course [ __ ] made
you know what i was gonna do
i had a small part in a movie i was
gonna do something called blue potato
last september and it didn't the dates
didn't end up working out it was all
about the oxy problem up there in maine
um so look for that movie because the
[ __ ] script was great
there you go there's a little inside
hollywood [ __ ] all right here we go
um she helped me get through my through
help me get throughout when my mom died
all right this guy did some oxy and when
he was doing the oxy he did not take a
spelling class
all right let's back up here help me get
through when my mom died
she stuck with me and helped me raise
and support my niece from the time she
was born till present
oh yeah this girl's a champ my niece is
now almost four
and now helping me support you jumping
back and forth here sir
so now this wonderful woman i'm gonna
help you out here is now helping me
support my father
who can't work due to him dying with
multiple
melanoma marrow cancer bone marrow
cancer jesus christ
um not melanoma myeloma
bone cancer i don't know how to read
that word sir
oh jesus bill just get to the end of
this [ __ ] thing
so we can all stop staring awkwardly
down at our pen and pencil set
okay guys here we go all of this while
holding a full-time job and going to
college to be a psychological nurse
psychological nurse okay
uh bill she is an angel and i don't know
what i would do without her but i have
one little problem over the last few
years she's been putting on the pounds
she loves to eat i dude i read in the
beginning of this
wife is getting heavy and i'm like
where's the left her i have the memory
of a
[ __ ] ant jesus christ bill
stop talking on the cell phone anyways
she's been putting on the pound she
loves to eat
i guess she stresses out with everything
but she's gained a lot of weight in the
last three years i'm talking at least 80
pounds no you can't have that
can't have that 80 pounds i mean
she's almost morbidly obese 100 pounds
is like morbidly obese 30 pounds
is obese so she's gonna [ __ ] die
um anyways he got to the point where she
almost weighed more than me and i'm not
a small guy
six feet 240 but in in shape for the
most part i've got at least five inches
height on her
and only weigh 10 to 15 pounds more than
her i'm not
it's not making me not want to tie the
knot with her
but if we're going to do it for the long
haul i don't want to have a heart attack
at the age of 40. how do i bring this up
because as all men know you don't bring
up a woman's
weight uh help me dollar dollar bills
all right
i'll tell you this is how you do it
you need to lose some weight right all
right
how do you do this what you got to do is
you bring her in the fold
by talking about your own shortcomings
with you you
you know whatever weight problem you
have
because what are you you're six feet
240.
you know dude you could stand to lose a
good 25 30 yourself you know
get down to that 215 210
you know you guys are getting married
just say you know what
let's [ __ ] uh you know watch one of
those late night things and just get her
into it you know what this is what you
do first
i got it this is what i would do with
her
uh you got all you're living up there in
maine it's absolutely gorgeous
just say you want to take her on a
picnic she likes food
all right well you don't say this is
going to be a mile-long hike
[Laughter]
and when she opens the picnic basket you
got brussels sprouts in there
right now you can't do it like that but
i i would
start enjoying the outdoors more and i
would get into some activities
and what i would do is
um just slowly if you guys are living
together just start introducing
healthier [ __ ] foods into the fridge
in the cabinets and toss another [ __ ]
and um just see how that works
and if she calls you on it you just
gotta come clean
just say honey i love you to death
you're the woman of my dreams
i want to marry you and the last thing i
ever want to do is hurt you and i just
don't know how to bring up that i'm
concerned
that i'm going to lose you and she'll be
like what are you talking about and if
you just bring it up with the fact that
you're concerned that you're gonna lose
her someday
um and you bring it into the weight
thing and then when she cries or
whatever blah blah hold her tell her you
love her and just say listen i gotta
lose some weight
too you help me through the oxy thing
all right
to the point i'm kind of punchy right
now let's
let's get our weight down for these kids
we don't have yet you know
just do that try that i'll see see how
that [ __ ] works and if it blows up in
your face i apologize
but i got to tell you that that that
hiking thing's a little sneaky
you know start going for walks
if you hold your their hand they don't
notice that they're hiking
you know
[Laughter]
that's what you do hold her hand hand
hold her hand and then have
have a guitar that you go [ __ ]
acoustic guitar you got it thrown around
your back like you're gonna serenade her
it should just be so blown away she
won't notice that you walk three miles
up a mountain
you know and then when you get up there
you just sing that
the bear went over the mouth
and all that he could see
i'm sorry girlfriend going to vegas
alone
oh god oh
as joe derosa says you hate to see it
ah you hate to see it i gotta have him
i'm gonna be going on new york next week
i should have him on the podcast next
week i should really do that
i'm gonna reach out to joe you know i'm
actually gonna reach out to his people
and see if they can get in touch with
joe he's just finishing the european leg
of his latest uh his latest cd
smash it what was it called something
personal i believe is what he put it out
is
anyways my girlfriend of two years and i
have a great relationship
we're in our 30s and get along better
than anyone i've dated before
i have no complaints you guys always
start this [ __ ]
like guys always just like [ __ ] love
her she's [ __ ] great but you know she
has a dick
all right he goes i have no complaint
with the way things are going neither of
us are looking at marriage in the future
she's divorced and doesn't want to try
again and i've never intended to get
married well then what you guys you [ __ ]
buddies
he goes we just enjoy each other's
company and i couldn't be happy with her
here's the thing she still gets the urge
to go out and dance to blow off some
steam sometime
but i avoid it it's not that i don't
know how to dance but let's just say
that i partied my way through college
and immersing myself in that scene again
only gets me into trouble with those
mood-enhancing substances
she's got a great job and unlike me can
afford to go on a little vacation she
picked vegas
and no i'm not the least bit worried
about her banging some other dude she's
into the ladies
oh she is and as an unwavering per and
as my unwavering permission to go out
and have her fun with them
as long as she's safe about it a
threesome has always been on the table
in the past but i honestly
think i'd opt out just so we don't have
the potential for any jealousy to show
its face in our relationship that's
that's a smart move
watching is good enough for me um anyway
back to the issue at hand i have no
issues with her going but i'm worried
that i'm not fulfilled
fulfilling her need to go out and party
that's what i was gonna say
um i was actually gonna suggest that uh
he said
let me go back here i'm not fulfilling
your need to go out and party at the
club every so often
and don't want it to build into a
serious problem she doesn't go clubbing
on the regular this is her first time
doing anything like this since we
started dating
do i need to grow the [ __ ] up put my
pass behind me and start taking my lady
out to the club
or i just let her keep going out on her
own
i think it's perfectly normal for two
people in relationship to have
activities that they do on their own
i'm into outdoor sports and she she's
into going dancing
we both need our adrenaline source uh
outside of our great sex life together
she says she's not planning on hooking
up with the lady while she's out there
and i wouldn't care either way but i am
setting myself but am i setting myself
up for
failure in the future not taking her out
myself
or do i just let her go and let her have
her fun uh i would tell her what you
told
me just say listen i did the party scene
in college in college
no start with saying like listen i'm
worried that because i don't take you
out dancing eventually that's going to
lead to x y and z
um and i have to tell you that the
reason why i take you out is not because
the reason i don't take you out is not
because i don't want to take you out
it's because i did the college
partying scene and i'm worried that if i
go into that scene again
i'm going to get in trouble with you
know whatever drugs you were using
you know so much of this relationship
[ __ ] is just [ __ ] taking a deep
breath and just saying it
you know saying why you're doing
whatever the [ __ ] it is that you're
doing
and uh you know you can't [ __ ] with
honesty
i mean you can be upset by it
i want to [ __ ] your friend there it's
out there
all right here we go third break oh my
god hound 15 minutes you guys got your
money's worth huh
here we go personal capital everybody
two things suck about managing your
money it's hard to keep track of
you got stocks bonds 401k ira
bank accounts etc all on different sites
with their own username and password
they literally just described my
financial situation and every month
i get like 19 statements and i look at
them and i rub my chin and i can't tell
which end is up so anyways they say here
then you pay someone to manage it and
you're probably paying too much
all right that's why you got to love
personal capital
it takes under a minute to set this up
just go to the podcast page on
billboard.com
and click the personal capital banner
then you can see your whole net worth
and how each asset is performing
on one screen on your computer or
through their app
on your phone or tablet doesn't get
easier than that then it shows you how
much you're paying
money managers and brokers and fees and
how you can reduce those fees
and even gives you specific areas where
you can improve your investment strategy
so in other words
the entire operation is transparent the
exact way you want it to be
when you're dealing with your money this
thing is really is a really smart way to
grow
and make your excuse me this thing is a
really smart way to make your mi
make oh this is a typo here
this thing is a really smart way to make
your money grow quicker
it's run by former the former ceo of
paypal and is totally free
to sign up for free go to the podcast
page on billboard.com
and click on the personal capital banner
there you are and finally father's day
is around the corner
what does that mean this father's day
what are you going to be thinking you
got to think the man great
what is the man great you ask they are
made in america cast iron grilling
grates that are revolutionizing the way
people grill
heavy-duty grilling grates deliver
exactly what you need to achieve that
perfect steakhouse flavor
chicken steak or veggies will never have
tasted so good you know the deal you go
out you buy your favorite grill
everything's cool you got the gas you
got the charcoal whatever you want to
use
but then they give you those little
wimpy that little wimpy grape
you know looks like a bunch of pretzel
rods welded together
this gives you this looks like those
stakeout ones the steakhouse ones you
know
the uh well i'll read more about here no
more flare-ups no more dry meat
guaranteed
name one of 2012's best grilling
accessories
by men's health magazine man greats are
perfect
the perfect gift for dad this father's
day go to man great dot com and enter
the coupon code bur
for their 1999 father's day special or
click the man great banner on the
website
100 made in america 100 cast iron
100 percent steakhouse quality
grilling in your backyard i got to tell
you i actually used something like this
uh i got that the giant egg and the only
reason why i didn't do the man breaks
because they don't have one big enough
for it but it's the exact same kind of
thing
it makes all the difference in the world
and i'm telling you
you're not gonna go wrong with this and
your dad he's gonna break down and cry
and hug you
and if he doesn't then i don't know what
i don't know what to tell you
[Music]
remember each monday morning podcast
order comes with a heavy duty grilling
brush
again that's the man great grill
enhancement system ordered today
man great.com great.commandgreat.com and
enter the coupon code burr b-u-r-r
at the checkout all right well that's
the podcast this week everybody
um i hope you guys have been enjoying
the nhl playoffs i know i talk about
them a lot but uh
they're really starting to get great i
haven't watched any of the uh
out the west but uh i love what the la
kings are doing
there's nothing i love seeing better
than when when it when a team that knows
how to win just just
just flips the switch it's it's a it's
an incredible thing to watch
it really is i haven't been they haven't
been watching but i've been watching the
results of their games
the [ __ ] guys did what do they do
they lost two
two in a row of the blues then came back
won the last four and they won the first
two against uh the
shacks and then the sharks won in
overtime
but um that's my dark horse
uh out west for taking out the uh
you know the winner of the blackhawks
red wings obviously the favorite is the
blackhawks
you gotta the the kings are very very
dangerous tape
and i'm obviously loving how the bruins
are playing but i gotta tell you the
penguins
have so much talent but the goaltending
is shaky
that's their achilles heel there you
know
and you know why they still have
achilles heel because matt cook plays
for him so he didn't slice it off with
his skate accidentally
[Laughter]
oh by the way phil jackson i got a gloat
here a little gloating moment at the end
of the podcast uh
phil jackson wrote a book and had some
interesting things to say about kobe so
i just want to
ask laker fans uh is he is he also a
hater
he won five championships with that guy
you know and if you read between the
lines of what phil jackson writes in his
book
about kobe all right you'll basically
have
exactly what the [ __ ] i've been saying
all right
so there you go i [ __ ] called it just
like paul versi
uh that's it that's the podcast for this
week once again thank you to everybody
who came out to the mirage uh
casino and thank you to the mirage
casino and everybody out in vegas that
really was a dream come true
um to perform at such a legendary casino
and have all those people come out
and uh got treated like a [ __ ] king
there
and we're actually hoping that that's
gonna be my my home base
and i can come out there because of the
turnover because every day i don't know
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
people leave hunt
another two hundred thousand come in um
i'm really hoping that um
that can become my home away from home
that's what we're gonna be working
towards so uh so that is it
for the podcast
you